[Music]
welcome back to science clique
today light cones and black holes
imagine lighting a candle
the candle emits a flash of light that
travels in all directions forming a
bubble that grows
this bubble is in three dimensions and
surrounds us completely
if we are inside this bubble it is
impossible to get out of it because we
would have to exceed the speed of light
imagine that we only perceive a 2d slice
of space
the bubble forms a circle that grows all
around us
[Music]
if we decompose the situation image by
image
and if we stack the images one after the
other
we can construct a diagram in which the
bubble of light which grows over time
forms a cone
this cone widens from the past to the
future
and inside of it we trace a trajectory
through time
the sides of the cone are tilted at 45
degrees because for any given amount of
time light always travels a set distance
in one year light will always travel a
distance of one light year through space
this type of object is called a light
cone
as time passes the cone expands at the
speed of light
and whatever we do our path remains
bounded by it
it's impossible to escape it
in relativity these light cones are
essential to understand the structure of
the universe
in particular they restrict cause and
effect relationships
to understand imagine an event that
occurs far from earth
such as a supernova explosion
this event won't be able to affect us
until its light cone has reached earth
[Music]
before that no information about the
explosion can reach us since nothing can
be transmitted faster than light
this explosion can only be seen and felt
on earth as soon as we enter its light
cone
causality the fact that one event can
trigger another
is limited by the speed of light
more importantly light cones allow us to
understand the profound difference
between the notions of time and space
what is the difference between time and
space
[Music]
through space we can move in any
direction turn around
or trace a path that loops back on
itself
but through time
all objects are forced to move in the
same direction
[Music]
in time it is impossible to turn back
we always move from the past towards the
future
[Music]
light cones allow us to clearly see this
difference
through space we are free to choose any
direction
but through time the successive light
cones force us to always move forwards
we cannot turn around because we are
bound to remain within these light cones
this property allows us to define rather
rigorously what we call time
time in relativity is simply the
direction in which the light cones are
oriented
it is this direction along which we
cannot turn back
the direction towards which all allowed
trajectories point and in which our
future necessarily lies
space on the other hand is the set of
all other directions perpendicular to
time
[Music]
in an area where the universe is empty
with no gravity its structure space-time
is straight
time and space form a symmetric
rectilinear grid and the light cones are
all aligned in the same direction
we can thus define time globally
in this diagram time goes from left to
right
but imagine now that the universe
contains a very massive body for
instance the earth
if we drop an apple the apple will
gradually fall downwards deflected by
the gravity of the planet
however gravity affects not only mata
but also light
if the apple emits bubbles of light over
time they will also be drawn downwards
[Music]
close to a massive body the light cones
are no longer aligned with each other
they curve more and more
bent by gravity
near a massive body the direction of the
light cones curves
and in other words
time
is bent towards the center of the planet
if the apple falls although it was
motionless at first it is because its
future points downwards
mass distorts the geometry of the
universe
space and time become relative their
orientation depending on where we are
this is general relativity
the more massive a body the more it
bends space-time
but imagine a massive object that is
very compact
such a body would generate a curvature
so strong
that below a certain altitude all light
cones would be completely oriented
downwards
if we were to light a candle in this
place all light rays whatever their
direction would be destined to fall
towards the center
this is what we call a black hole
a black hole is a spherical region of
the universe
a sort of bubble in which the curvature
of space-time drives all objects towards
the center
[Music]
if we consider a 2d slice of space
the black hole manifests as a circle
which stays static
and traces a cylinder through space-time
[Music]
the boundary of the black hole is called
the horizon
above the horizon some light rays can
escape
but below the horizon all light is
captured
in a black hole light cones force the
path of any object downwards
time itself points towards the center of
the black hole
[Music]
to understand what a black hole really
is it is wise to consider two different
points of view
that of an astronaut who falls into the
black hole
and that of a distant observer stationed
at a great distance
for the distant observer gravity is very
weak and in his vicinity the grid of
space-time is flat
for him time flows from left to right
the horizon of the black hole seems
motionless as it traces a straight line
from the past to the future
but let's now take the perspective of
the falling astronaut
as she gets closer to the horizon time
and space curve more and more bent by
the presence of the black hole
when she finally reaches the horizon of
the black hole the astronaut does not
realize it but at this point time and
space are tilted at 45 degrees
for the astronaut the horizon is not a
horizontal line from the past to the
future
it's a diagonal which rises at 45
degrees
exactly like the surface of a light cone
[Music]
while the distant observer sees the
black hole as stationary
for the astronaut at the horizon time
and space are tilted
such that the black hole behaves like a
light cone
which explains why it is impossible to
escape
[Music]
when she crosses the horizon the notions
of time and space seem swapped around
compared to the outside
time is now pointing downwards which
before was a direction through space
the horizon of the black hole is no
longer a place in space but a moment in
our past
and the center of the black hole is no
longer a point but an event in our
future
a destiny we cannot avoid
below the horizon all objects inevitably
full because it is in this direction
that their future lies
when a massive star collapses in on
itself
it emits one last flash of light a last
bubble that tries to grow
but within a curved space-time bent by
the mass of the star
such that the bubbles seem static from
the outside
a black hole has formed
[Music]
it is a light cone
rendered motionless by the curvature of
space-time
if we straighten back the diagram we
recover a global direction of time from
left to right
in this straightened diagram we see
explicitly that the horizon of the black
hole forms a light cone emerging from
the collapsing star and from the inside
of which it is impossible to escape
once below the horizon we are forced to
hit the center a place where the
curvature becomes so intense that our
models no longer
work the center of the black hole is an
event
in the future
finally if we compactify this diagram we
get a penrose diagram
in which the outside and the inside of
the black hole form two distinct regions
as soon as we cross the horizon the rest
of the universe is behind us in our past
we won't ever be able to access it again
our only possible future
is to fall
to the singularity
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you